hey guys welcome to another episode of
the Wednesday checkup feels like we
haven't done one of those intros in a
while that's because we've been busy
talking about the novel coronavirus
today we're going to be looking at some
of the most common conspiracy theories
I've seen and heard out there Shane
Dawson I'm looking at you we're doing
the medical version medical conspiracy
time
coronavirus in 2018 and Bill Gates was
somehow responsible Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation is one of the most
humanitarian foundations in the world
financially speaking they're literally
doing everything they can to eradicate
disease bring fresh water to people and
we're gonna blame this on them Japanese
doctors treating covid-19 cases say that
you should ensure your mouth and throat
are moist never dry so make sure you're
taking a few sips of water every 15
minutes skeptical to the source I don't
know if necessarily Japanese doctors
came out and said this but there's
partial truth to it if you have dry
mucous membranes they are more likely to
crack when they crack you actually have
a higher possibility of getting infected
with a bacteria or virus so yeah you
should be staying well hydrated you
should be drinking will it protect you
100 no but it's a good way to make sure
that you're doing the best you can to
stay healthy hand dryers are effective
at killing coronavirus I don't think
that's the case it certainly hasn't been
proven also CDC recommends drying your
hands through the air dry method which
is you just naturally let your hands dry
or using a paper towel reason being
there was a study that I actually talked
about on this channel that showed those
ultra high speed dryers actually blow
bacteria and viruses all over the place
especially if you don't wash your hands
well with this virus having fecal oral
spread meaning that toilet sinks can be
quite messy especially in public
restrooms you don't want to be blowing
that bacteria and viruses all over the
place so no I don't think air dryers
will kill the virus and I don't think
you should be using them you can create
your own hand sanitizer using Tito's
vodka I was almost going to say like
yeah it's possible to create your own
not with vodka not with Tito's vodka I
actually think Tito's vodka came out and
had to make a statement on this because
people were doing this based off a tick
tock video no you cannot use titles
vodka which I think is only 40 alcohol
to create a hand sanitizer like that
just not recommended if you're going to
be using some kind of disinfectant the
recommendation would be to use rubbing
alcohol that being said soap and water
soap and water soap and water gargling
with salt water or vinegar will
eliminate the covid-19 coronavirus we
have no evidence of that I actually do
recommend salt water gargles to a lot of
my patients not for eliminating viruses
just because it soothes a sore throat if
you have mucus buildup it helps clear
the mucus especially if you have like
post nasal drip or really chronic sore
throat but to kill the virus we don't
have evidence of that also this virus
seems to be very infectious in
comparison to the influenza virus for
example so if it touches your mucous
membranes right away it's going to start
infecting the rest of your body it has a
long incubation period but a quick
infection period if that makes any sense
coronavirus originated with Chinese
people eating bats from open air markets
okay I heard this one and initially I
was almost ready to buy into that
because you know other cultures eat
different animals so I wasn't one to
judge however when I looked into this I
found that the initial picture that
started this reporting actually didn't
come from China it came from a reporter
that was eating in an Asian country not
China some kind of local delicacy
nothing to do with the cuisine that's
actually consumed in China so no we have
no evidence of this coming from bat soup
we need to stop that we initially
thought that this virus started in bats
somehow made its way to humans probably
through a mutation there could have been
an intermediate carrier along the way so
perhaps a bat passed it to another
animal and then we got it to humans we
don't know that yet we're going to be
investigating and again let's think
smart here we're trying to combat this
prevent spread flatten the curve I
mentioned that in my other video which
basically decreases The Strain that's
put on our Health Care Systems what's
the use in talking about bat soup
outside of getting clicks
the most dangerous or at-risk place you
can go is a train or Subway the most
dangerous place you could probably go is
a hospital or an emergency room with
people sneezing and coughing all over
the place that is why we've been
directing patients to call in ahead of
time to figure out if their symptoms are
mild enough so we can get them to stay
home so they don't spread their virus
and they don't catch anyone else's one
of the biggest problems we face in the
hospital is known as nosocomial
infection I know it's a mouthful
basically means that you got sick from
being in the hospital if you notice
doctors are always trying to get all the
tests done give you all your treatments
so we can send you home from the
hospital it's not because we don't enjoy
having you there it's because we don't
want you to catch a disease accidentally
in the hospital it happens there's sick
people all around some people don't wash
their hands well they sneeze in the
hallway you walk through it there's all
sorts of issues so while I do think
being a crowded Subway is not good being
in a place where there's a lot of sick
people is probably it's had worse that's
why you should be going Point only in
cases of emergency or when you need
serious medical advice or help that's
why most routine procedures surgeries
well checks all have been pushed aside
in order to prevent patients from coming
in and catching covid-19 The Simpsons
predicted the coronavirus The Simpsons
the novels no no one could have
predicted this yes we knew that there
was a possibility of another pandemic
happening it happens with each
generation I think it happens the last
one that to me Rings the biggest Bell is
the Spanish Flu of 1918. that claimed
millions of lives hopefully now with
modern medicine our ability to
communicate our ability to create
technology like vaccines and antiviral
medications rather quickly hopefully
we're going to do a better job an Irish
company is preparing to release rapid
covid-19 testing kits which can provide
results in 15 minutes that would be
awesome because we need more testing
kits and if we can get them done quickly
very important however these tests
especially the rapid ones need to be
heavy heavily scrutinized through
clinical trials because we need to
establish the sensitivity and
specificity of those tests both of those
need to be high I'll explain each of
them a test that has high sensitivity is
good for screening meaning taking
General people in the population and
trying to find out if they have a
specific disease in a highly sensitive
test you have few false negatives on a
highly specific test you have few false
positives the ideal way of doing this is
you give someone as a screening test a
highly sensitive one and then you can
give them a highly specific test to
confirm that diagnosis now in a test
like this where you're testing people
who are already sick it's not
necessarily screening it's more
Diagnostic and a good diagnostic test
has both High sensitivity and
specificity there are many supplements
and other cures that can fight off the
coronavirus we have zero evidence for
any of those statements and I'm so proud
of the FDA for prosecuting those
individuals trying to make claims like
this John Oliver had a segment of
someone trying to sell silver as a way
to get rid of the virus
no no and if you're a supplement
manufacturer or you have your own line
of supplements please do not use this as
a moment to Brand your product that is a
cheap shot praying at folks
vulnerabilities at a very sensitive time
we should be banding together not trying
to figure out how to make a buck off
each other four women in Wuhan have
given birth to babies who do not have
the coronavirus unlike their mothers
there's been some evidence showing that
what we call vertical transmission from
the mother to the baby inside the uterus
there isn't transmission that's not to
say it can't happen but the evidence for
it does look promising we're hoping it
stays that way I do recommend checking
out Mama Dr Jones she does a fantastic
job talking all things OB GYN
coronavirus included links down below
here's a playlist of some medical memes
for you to learn and laugh from because
laughter is good medicine and here's
another playlist of my Reddit series
check it out which one you're gonna
click on while you stay happy and
healthy
[Music]